passe la parole à Monsieur Roger
caoutchi pour le groupe UMP
chez le président monsieur le ministre
on l'a dit et tout le monde l'a dit donc
je vais poursuivre la lutte la
prévention du terrorisme sont évidemment
des éléments qui dépassent largement
tous les clivages il y a eu des textes
en 2006 en 2008 votre texte de loi de
2012 reprend amplifie l'action conduite
et c'est très bien
mais c'est vrai monsieur le ministre que
depuis quelques temps à travers de la
fermera mais au travers aussi d'autres
affaires il y a eu un certain nombre de
critiques parfois excessive sur les
dysfonctionnements et je voudrais dans
un premier temps dire que la République
de manière générale doit rendre hommage
à tous ses agents des services
intérieurs et extérieurs qui risquent
leur vie au quotidien sans toujours
beaucoup de reconnaissance mais ce qui
amène ma question aujourd'hui c'est un
rapport qui a été déposé la semaine
dernière
qui dit que en gros à la suite des
différentes études il faudrait pendant
un certain nombre de mesures avec par
exemple
la création d'une inspection des
services avec par exemple une autorité
indépendante pour voir par exemple
quelle est la proportionnalité des
éléments mis à la disposition pour
obtenir des renseignements à l'extérieur
ou à l'intérieur en clair on va devoir
on va favoriser
le fait d'accéder à un certain nombre de
renseignements de mieux contrôler alors
la transparence elle a du bon parfois
mais elle peut être aussi un peu
inquiétante elle peut être aussi un
élément de doute de danger pour les
agents qui eux sont en mission sur le
terrain alors Monsieur le Ministre ma
question est assez simple oui les
renseignements doivent être coordonnés
oui vous l'avez dit le lien desse des
séries oui il faut renforcer les moyens
de la dessérie mais quels sont les
mesures que vous envisagez de prendre
pour faire en sorte que au travers et
avec la transparence nécessaire
notamment pour le Parlement il n'y ait
pas en revanche au travers de cette
remise en cause parfois de la
confidentialité de risques de danger
pour l'ensemble de nos agents à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur parce
qu'après tout il défendent aussi et
l'État et la République
merci monsieur le ministre
ce président monsieur le ministre je
partage au fond ce que vous venez de
dire et notamment dans votre
introduction il y a un besoin de
transparence et nos grandes démocraties
notamment le Parlement doivent pouvoir
traiter ces questions de renseignement
de manière sereine et avec le souci du
respect de la loi et en même temps nous
devons protéger ces agents qui servent
les intérêts fondamentaux de l'autre
pays le rapport de Jean-Jacques urvoise
du président de la commission des lois
l'assemblée vient d'être remis il nous
faut peu de temps pour en tirer tous les
conclusions mais en tout cas je vais
vous dire que il me semble et je vais
dans le sens du rapport nécessaire en
premier lieu de renforcer les bâches
juridiques de l'action des services de
renseignement la plupart des grandes
démocraties ont engagé de telles
démarches en mettant en place des outils
qui sont protecteurs et il faut
reconnaître que notre pays encore du mal
à les concevoir et c'est cet équilibre
là qu'il nous faut évidemment trouver de
ce point de vue là les conclusions de la
mission urvoyoise sont ambitieuse et me
semble-t-il bienvenue même si après il
faut les examiner dans le détail elles
posent les jalons d'une réflexion qui
pourra opportunément être menée sur ce
sujet là dans les prochains mois et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avions
commencé à faire dans le cadre de la loi
anti-terroriste d'autres questions se
posent sur les bases juridiques de
l'action des services de renseignement
tels que par exemple l'opportunité nous
en avions discuté ici même de faire
évoluer la loi de 1881 dont chacun
pourra convenir qu'elle n'offre pas un
cadre adapté aux réalités du monde
contemporain je pense aux notes de
prescription de publicité sur internet
et les réseaux sociaux par exemple les
services de renseignement demandent ces
bases juridiques davantage solidifiées
et qui les protège il y a une demande de
transparence du Parlement et de la
société et en même temps nous devons
protéger ses agents et permettre surtout
l'efficacité des services qui demandent
évidemment du secret elle est là la
ligne de crête que nous devons trouver
ensemble merci monsieur Roger garouci
très brièvement monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre c'est évident que
c'est une ligne de crête autant le
Parlement comme l'opinion veulent savoir
autant nous savons bien que ceux qui
décident ce qui donne les instructions
ont aussi besoin souvent beaucoup de
secrets de discrétion si on veut
l'efficacité donc naturellement il y a
un équilibre à trouver et bien entendu
nous serons extrêmement vigilants sur
cet équilibre pour ne pas remettre en
cause la sécurité la confidentialité et
l'efficacité de nos